bonsoir à toutes et à tous rien n'est
impossible
soirée exceptionnelle en direct et en
public sur rmc story le canal 23 de la
tête
vos trente propositions de lois
citoyenne le 7 janvier dernier sur rmc
et rmc découverte nous vous demandions
de nous envoyer vos propositions pour
faire avancer la france dans cette crise
des gilets jaunes construire au lieu de
détruire 25000 contributions reçues
nos journalistes rmc rmc découvertes ont
retenu les 60 propositions le plus
souvent cité est depuis le 15 février
vous pouvez voter vous votez pour
dresser la liste de vos trente
propositions de lois citoyenne
découvrons les votes
[Musique]
chiffre 2
93 1283 votants c'est un succès
considérable depuis le 14 février en dix
jours 93000 de 183 votants résultat
exceptionnel vous pouvez voter jusqu'au
14 mars
le 15 mars nous remettrons vos trente
propositions aux élus de la république
le président de la république le premier
ministre les membres du gouvernement les
parlementaires députés et sénateurs mais
aussi les membres du conseil économique
social et environnemental ainsi que les
députés européens
nous vous donnons la parole comme je le
fais depuis tant d'années ce soir nous
allons découvrir vos trente propositions
de lois citoyenne celle qui arrive en
tête sur les 60 propositions soumises au
vote
sont-elles raisonnable ou pas sont elles
efficaces ou pas sont-elles réalisable
ou pas quatre experts indépendants vont
nous aider
tout au long de la soirée il vienne me
rejoindre et jouez vous les présente
madame monsieur bonsoir je vais
commencer avec arnaud vad
bonsoir serge guérin bonsoir jean marc
jancovici
bonsoir et mathieu plane pour installer
vous je vais vous présenter
je vais m'asseoir avec vous et je vais
vous présenter à nos vad
professeur de droit constitutionnel
présidente de l'association française de
droit constitutionnel par les
institutions initialement avec anne
levade jean marc jancovici qui est
ingénieur membre du haut conseil pour le
climat serge guérin qui est sociologue
enseignant en sciences politiques et
spécialiste de toutes les questions
concernant le troisième âge le quatrième
âge la signorina seniorisation bon et
puis mathieu plane qui est économiste à
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques merci madame merci messieurs
d'être avec nous ce soir vous allez
pouvoir intervenir quand ce n'est pas
votre domaine n'hésitez pas et puis
notre public va pouvoir intervenir va
pouvoir réagir tout au long de la soirée
pourquoi sommes nous là nous sommes là
pour essayer de d'expliquer pour essayer
de comprendre nous avons demandé à nos
auditeurs à nos téléspectateurs de nous
envoyer leurs propositions dans le cadre
de cette crise ddj les jeunes pour faire
avancer les choses
ensuite les politiques se saisiront de
ces propositions ou pas c'est leur
problème ce n'est pas le nôtre
nous nous donnons les outils ensuite les
politiques choisiront et pour comprendre
la situation n'a besoin de vous j'ai
besoin de tout ce que vous savez j'ai
besoin de faire comprendre aux uns et
aux autres et je l'entends tous les
jours sans arrêt j'ai besoin de faire
comprendre pourquoi les propositions
sont intéressantes ou pourquoi ne sont
pas ou pourquoi c'est impossible
alors nous allons découvrir les dix
premières et ensuite dans la deuxième
partie de l'émission
nous développerons les autres
propositions les dix premières
j'ai commencé avec la 10e la dixième
proposition pour l'instant diminution
des indemnités des parlementaires et des
ministres voilà c'est la proposition 29
1175 votant pour cette proposition qui
demande
la diminution des indemnités des
parlementaires et des ministres
anne levade qu'en pensez vous
franchement alors d'abord je voudrais
dire que les indemnités des
parlementaires et des ministres ont déjà
été réduites en particulier seuls des
ministres par françois hollande quand il
a entamé son mandat il a baissé les
indemnités des ministres de 30% ainsi
d'ailleurs que la sienne et celle du
premier ministre
donc c'est un travail qui a déjà été
engagée voilà donc derrière il faut pas
oublier non plus que le mot d'indemnités
à son importance c'est à dire que l'idée
dans une démocratie et que ceux qui nous
gouvernent sont des citoyens qui à un
moment donné s'engagent au service de
l'intérêt général soit parce qu'ils sont
élus en tant que parlementaire soit
parce qu'ils sont nommés en tant que
membre du gouvernement et donc l'idée de
l'indemnité dit bien ce qu'elle veut
dire c'est à dire il s'agit pas d'un
salaire il s'agit pas d'une rémunération
pour un métier
il s'agit d'un elysée le temps passé au
service de la collectivité et j'insiste
parce que c'est une idée très importante
parce que c'est aussi ce qui permet que
puisse devenir une autre question est là
c'est sociologue qui pourrait être une
autre question est de savoir si c'est la
réalité
mais c'est ce qui permet que quelqu'un
qui n'a pas de revenus et fortunes
personnelles puissent s'engager en
politique
le risque le risque si l'on diminue trop
les indemnités le risque c'est quoi
c'est d'encourager la corruption ce
risque là c'est jean marc jancovici oui
non non moi j'avais joué juste faire une
remarque à rouillon sens aller qui est
l'afrique elle fasse maintenant si la
vraie question c'est est ce que ces gens
là coûte trop cher au pays je pas sur
quoi qu'ils coûtent trop cher pour la
valeur qu'on perçoit ce qui à mon avis
est beaucoup plus proche du sens de la
réponse c'est à dire en gros ils y
gagneront toujours trop d'argent
oui pour
le l'impression qu'ils donnent de leur
dévouement à la collectivité crise est
une absolue mans indispensable jean marc
jancovici les sujets environnementaux
les sujets techniques pour parler de ce
que je connais il ya un grand hiatus qui
est que ceux qui bossent sont pas connus
et ceux qui sont connus bosse pas si je
fais très court
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas à la fois
dans une politique s'occuper de
conquérir le pouvoir et bosser ces
dossiers donc pas donc pas la force des
choses ce qu'on voit chez vous et ceux
qui travaillent le moins qu'ils n'ont
pas le temps non mais c'est je pense
qu'une partie du ressenti de la
population vis-à-vis des élus vient de
là mais peut-être parce que la populace
n'hésitez pas ce que fait oui le le
parlementaire mais le ia le travail le
travail par an et puis tout le travail
qu'on ne connaît pas les émissions
l'autre souvent c'est la caméra on voit
les questions du mercredi mercredi à la
chambre elle est quasiment vide comme
ceux qui sont pas là fallait pour
lesquelles après pour faire les dents et
de la survie certains en fait ils ont
passé leur vie à bosser ils proviennent
pas à ce mois puis d'autres c'est un peu
l'un vers 9 heures non mais ça
effectivement c'est la réalité je
voulais je voulais juste prolongé ce qui
vient d'être dit moi j'aime pas l'idée
du ressenti ce qui est vrai c'est que je
pense que c'est une proposition qui est
le prolongement en presque logique du
discrédit et politique on reste à tous
aujourd'hui et que certains partagent
mais je crois que ce discrédit il vient
sans doute non pas tant de ce que les
gens ressentent que du fait que la
politique n'aboutit pas toujours au
résultat qu'on pourrait espérer et donc
de ce point de vue là il ya
effectivement cette idée que peut-être
ça n'est pas mon sentiment ils sont trop
payés pour ce qu'ils font
j'ajoute que l'indemnité des
parlementaires et 2 1 1380 euros par
mois l'indemnité de l'indemnité ce qu'on
appelle l'indemnité de base auxquels
s'ajoutent
le remboursement des frais l'argent pour
deux représentations collaborateurs mais
je j'ajoute que cette indemnité elle est
d'abord conçu et c'est pour ça que le
mot est important elle est d'abord conçu
pour protéger un système démocratique et
donc pour garantir que ceux qui nous
représentent le fond le plus
objectivement possible sans
effectivement [ __ ] d'être acheté par
d'autres financements non je vous arrête
pas qu'elle va falloir que on la vend
sous les roues ont des rouges je dis
simplement vous fournir un chiffre
s'ils ont divisé par deux les indemnités
de nos parlementaires on économiserait
on économiserait 30 millions d'euros
c'est à la fois beaucoup et peu millions
d'habitants ça fait par an je n'étais
pas bon
nous allons passer à la 9ème opposition
9e et pour parler de cette 9e
proposition stéphane est avec 47 ans
fonctionnaire territorial dans les
hauts-de-seine aller où est mon micro il
l'a et stéphane alors thomas stéphane
parent donc je m'installe excusez moi
alors stéphane je vous tend le micro
que vouliez-vous dire à propos de cette
proposition numéro 9
je vous donne la proposition baisser la
tva pour les produits de première
nécessité et l'augmentait pour les
produits de luxe
alors c'est sûr que ce serait une mesure
qui serait intéressante pour les classes
basses de la population qui pourraient
accéder à plus beaucoup plus facilement
à se nourrir et à différentes différents
services parce que c'est vrai que la la
la tva actuellement est à 5,5 sur les
biens de 2 1 mais s'est réservée surtout
sur les médicaments les choses comme ça
donc ce serait pas mal de cas mais la
presse également et ce serait pas mal de
pouvoir donc de baisser de baisser ce
taux
après c'est vrai que en y réfléchissant
bien
ça peut être une arme à deux tranchants
parce que ça peut faire remonter aussi
les marges et les producteurs et des
distributeurs
donc on y gagnerait peut-être pas
grand-chose mais ce serait quand même
été au consommateur n'y gagnerait pas
voilà dans les choses bien merci
beaucoup je reviens vers vous mathieu
plane alors que pensez vous de cette
proposition
vous allez allez assez intéressante sur
un certain nombre de points il faut
juste revoir le cadre un peu dans lequel
on s'inscrit c'est à dire et notamment
la question européenne est aujourd'hui à
des normes en europe qui définissent les
différents types de taux de tva on a un
taux de tva normal un taux de tva
intermédiaire à un taux réduit
après il ya le taux super réduit mais
qui pour des raisons historiques et la
presse et les médicaments
mais la norme du taux réduit en europe
peut pas être en dessous de 5%
voilà donc la marge de manoeuvre ou
alors c'est la directive de l'union
européenne
revoir cette directive qui est très
compliqué parce qu'il faut l'unanimité
on voit la taxe dégâts etc
mais bon parler et donc en fait alors
jouanno assez assez réduite à dire qu'on
prépare ses de 5 5 à 5 et se pose la
question est ce qu'on met tous les biens
de consommation qui sont à sauter et
demi à 5 % ou juste certains mais
mathieu plane conséquence d'abord on
pourrait bon pour qu'on peut tendre le
cou à l'europe n'est pas comique et un
c'est compliqué bon second plus c'est
compliqué on peut pas donc on peut pas
passer à 0
on ne trouve pas masser à 0 on peut pas
passer comme ça à 0 c'est en restant
dans un cadre européen aujourd'hui au
caire mais ont peu baissé à 5 mais on
peut pas pas cela on peut baisser à 5 et
après se pose la question sur quels
types de biens fait quoi c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
d'activités de loisirs par exemple par
une attraction le cinéma le théâtre
l'opéra soit 5 5 5 mais il ya aussi tous
l'alimentaire et dans l'alimentaire vous
avez différentes choses serre que on a
travaillé là-dessus cirque on peut se
poser la question c'est y aller nutri
score c'est à dire des biens
alimentaires en fonction de leurs
qualités nutritives
on pourrait identifier des produits en
disant effectivement ils ont un besoin
alimentaire qui vient qu'il peut être
différent d'autres biens alimentaires
parce que vous avez beaucoup de choses
alimentaire oui on pourrait taxer à 20%
des produits car sont pas très bons
l'écologie l'environnement même pour
notre santé c'est con qu'est-ce que vous
avez c'est jean marc jancovici
je me souviens que c'était le principe
de la tse le passé de la taxe carbone et
c'est celle qui nous vous le plaisir
d'être ici donc je sais pas que c'est
nécessairement une mauvaise idée
alors je joue un an fait pour compléter
ce qui vient des 10 le le problème de ce
genre de mesure apprécié que le diable
est dans les détails c'est à dire quand
vous rentrez dans l'inventaire à la
prévert de ce qui est éligible est pas
éligible
c'est vrai vous voyez des boules et tout
le monde qui à votre porte qu'il y est
mais moi je suis dans la catégorie moi
je suis dans les jolis pas certain que
le consommateur en sorte gagnant +1
je ne sais pas où ils manient exemple
très fort pour l'histoire des cafés
restaurants on nous avait laissé la taxe
fera baisser la tva est globalement les
restaurateurs ont augmenté tarifs en ont
profité et a créé oui après ses seins de
soutien décidé par an pour moi le
chocolat de première nécessité mais
quand quelqu'un d'autre non alors qu à
laquelle nous on va mettre à zéro
ainsi donc on voit que c'est hyper
subjectif mais ce que vous permet de
rappeler quand même par rapport à
l'actualité récente c'est quand on dit
oui les gens qui ont peu de moyens payés
par les impôts à ces fuites ils payent
pas l'impôt sur le revenu ni la tva il
cela traîne en place il le rappeler
quelles que soient ses revenus
importants et canton mais c'est pour ça
que la leçon première nécessité est
super intéressante par rapport à ça mais
à quel moment où une place là la
première nécessité c'est vrai que après
ça serait la question de la localisation
l'écologie met en porte sacré pas mais
on sent que c'est quand même un peu une
usine à gaz juste oui pour terminer la
joyeuse bande du coup sûr la question du
pouvoir d'achat ça serait assez faible
en fait henri fait de toute façon serait
de 5 5 à 5 sur certains produits
peut-être pas tous les produits est donc
fréquent plus les distributeurs le
répercute intégralement dans les prises
qui veut dire que ça changerait pas
tradi calment alors eu quelques mots sur
la tva 130 milliards d'euros c'est ça le
sera contre 150 milliards d'euros mais
maintenant le premier impôt jusque-là
jaune
oui c'est deux fois plus que la peau
seront pas beaucoup mais c'est tout le
monde et la réalité même vous payez plus
le poids de la tva dans
oui d'autant plus important que vous
êtes en bas de l'échelle des revenus ce
que votre consommation vous êtes au smic
globalement on consomme et intégralement
votre revenu donc vous payer la tva au
même taux que tout le monde alors que
les hauts revenus vont épargner une
partie et paieront pas relaté mathieu
mathieu dans le dans la proposition est
contenue l'idée aussi d'augmenter la tva
sur les produits de luxe la faire passer
à 30 ou 33 % travail ça existe et
attendrait désormais on a un plafond qui
serait de 25 % pourrait et après la
question aussi ses fictions il ya des
règles on peut pas multiplier les taux
de tva et déjà on peut pas la route
au delà de 25 on a un taux normal fille
est pas un taux au dessus mais comment
font les autres pays d'europe
ils font comme tout ou à peu près en
même temps dire non mais à quelque chose
près à presser les biens qu'ils vont
changer non un taux de tva intermédiaire
tout réduit non l'intermédiaire on a mis
effectivement la restauration emporté
parce qu'elle est plein de raisons sa
part emporter ou sur place
il ya eu des choix qui ont été faits des
arbitrages mais c'est vrai que c'est ce
qui a été dit ces recrues si on commence
à rentrer dans le détail ça devient
extrêmement complexe et par exemple
qu'est ce qu'on appelle un produit de
luxe automobile mais servent tout
automobile pourrait être un bien de luxe
mais entre une ferrari ou une clio vous
avez quand même une grosse cagnotte
hotelia sur une automobile aujourd'hui
weill a vendu 100 0 20% et pourquoi est
ce qu'on ne mettrait pas un taux de tva
à 5% sur une automobile électrique ou
sur une automobile qui est bonne pour
notre environnement
on pourrait très bien mettre une
fiscalité spécifique sur les alors en
fait cette idée là on peut la reprendre
sur certaines catégories d'objets bien
précises
ouais c'est ce qu'on avait évoqué la
dernière fois par exemple la vignette
oui j'avais connu et moi aussi c'est que
vous défendez la vigne est absolument ça
vous pouvez très bien la moduler en
fonction de la taille du véhicule
du coup ça rend chèvre rare que les gens
qui sont tout en bas de l'échelle
achètent des ferrari 9ème de cadres et
donc vous pouvez très bien moduler la
vignette en fonction de la taille du
véhicule et ça devient en pratique
quelque chose qui se rapproche d'un
impôt progressif un peu dans cet esprit
là dans cet esprit là non c'est très
intéressant vous pouvez continuer à
voter pour vous pouvez vous continuez à
voter à combien là quel est le nombre de
votes on va voir
sur rmc.fr vous votez ça va s'afficher
ne vous inquiétez pas je vais le faire
tout au long de l'a2 la soirée jc à la
réalisation 93 1369 votants 93 1369
votants bon nous étions en neuvième
position
passons à la huitième position
en huitième position augmentation des
effectifs et des salaires dans la
fonction publique hospitalière je dis
bien hospitalière ça c'est une demande
qui revient très très très souvent il ya
un besoin comme si on avait envie de
reconnaître le travail effectué dans la
fonction publique hospitalière serge
guérin alors je crois que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très fort c'est d'abord
que les gens ont conscience 1 qu' ils
peuvent être malades ou bête que deux on
a quand même un système de soins qui est
quand même assez génial d'abord qui
écrit en une le préserver en vie le
préserver intéressant mais on se rend
compte que ça coûte une journée
d'hospitalisation à l'hôpital on devrait
le savoir que coûte se veut que ce que
va coûter à la collectivité la journée
qu'on va face et a loupé ça parce que
j'en ai c'est gratuit dont il faut bien
quelqu'un paye c'est pas gratuit où on a
la chance extraordinaire en france soit
6 % à dire qu'il ya plein de gens
l'étranger qui viennent voilà la chance
que il ya une gratuité d'accès aux soins
et c'est génial sauf que ça a un coût et
qui paye ainsi de suite et là dedans
les gens en ont bien conscience je
trouve ça assez fort parce que c'est
aussi comment on crée une société qui
est vivable pour tout le monde à travers
le fait qu'il ya des personnes qui sont
là dont le métier est d'accompagner les
autres d'aider et de soigner d'autres
et tout ça ça fait énormément monde et
les gens le voient bien qu'on parle des
jets des jaunes on a bien vu comme
beaucoup de gens sur les ronds-points
souvent des femmes d'ailleurs parce que
le gros de la fonction publique
hospitalière
en tout cas dans les degrés les plus bas
les moins bien payés ce sont à 85 % des
femmes parfois aussi des femmes seules
qui élèvent des enfants pourrait vite
qui saoule on démultiplie comme ça les
difficultés parfois les happy few et
autres et donc on voit bien que si on
veut que les personnes la soigne mieux
bon égoïstement je dirais qu'elle
s'occupe mieux de nous dans l'intérêt
mieux les payer mathieu oui non il faut
rappeler ça sert que fit ya un
attachement un autre modèle social un
cas certaines particularités
il faut rappeler aussi que la dépense de
santé c'est le deuxième poste le plus
important dans la dépense publique après
les retraites ans et plus de 200
milliards par an donc c'est colossal
donc se pose toujours la question du
financement
c'est à dire quelle forme et dans ce
débat là c'est à dire que moi je suis
assez d'accord effectivement la question
et ses centrales hors de la fonction
publique hospitalière des effectifs
éventuellement des rémunérations il ya
de ta question des heures sup d'ailleurs
mais après il ya toujours la question du
financement enfin c'est aujourd'hui ce
qui finance la santé c'est la csg donc
la question c'est est ce qu'on doit
monter la cg pour mieux financer
justement les services de santé
pour rappel j'ai regardé les
statistiques j'étais un peu surpris
c'est que quand on regarde ce qui s'est
fait sur les dix dernières années en
fait les effectifs de la fonction
publique hospitalière encore augmenter
de façon assez nette
map de quasiment 10% sur les dix
dernières années c'est plus que la
population ce qui est un peu paradoxale
être un coeur il ya un effet la violence
était avant mais toujours sur les
anciens est toujours intéressant de dire
effectivement il faut peut-être plus
effective plus de salaire et après aussi
accepté un financement et est encore une
fois encore une fois l'idée que nous
soulevions tout de suite que nous
proposions c'était de savoir ce que
coûte l'utilisent usage du service
public
et puis c'est aussi d'arriver oui c'est
vrai c'est très très et s'il avait
raison les gens il faut qu'on retrouve
concrètement un contrat pour faire une
chose et j'en canton loin dans la rue y
avait une étude viavoice comme ça j'en
dirais 15000 euros 34 c'est mon pas
content parce qu'en même temps ces
scellés expertisés vous faut aussi
rappeler il n'ya pas ta fonction
publique hospitalière il ya aussi le
privé institué le typhon et puis l'autre
élément c'est que nous nous tous avons
quand on est des aidants oui donc
bénévoles gratuit si on payait au même
prix ça serait 64 milliard d'euros faut
il mettre sur la table en plus y'a que
les premiers contributeurs du soin en
fait c'est les gens c'est vous et moi
quand on accompagne un parent malade un
enfant handicapé
j'en passe et là aussi comment on
valorise cela et ça c'est un petit peu
les invisibles aussi généralement ce
sont des femmes en septième position
indexation ça ça va vous vous intéressez
serge guérin indexation des retraites
sur l'inflation ou sur le salaire moyen
s'est passé en rond c'est pas ça en
septième position pourtant fait ça
c'est la sixième non on va vous dire il
ya un monde qui a changé alors la course
au dernier moment alors en sixième on
limite les rémunérations des hauts
fonction s'est passé les rênes sont
passés devant
ah oui limiter les rémunérations des
hauts fonctionnaires faire en sorte
qu'elle ne soit pas supérieure à celle
du président de la république anne
levade les ans fonctionnaire s'est on
n'en parlait pas et tout à coup avec la
crise des gilets jaunes ont tenu à
parler des hauts fonctionnaires qui
était dans l'ombre ya la crise et les
gilet jaune ya eu quelques publications
aussi sorti un livre qui a révélé
quelque chose et en particulier le fait
que 1 % la très haute fonction publique
aurait effectivement un niveau de
rémunération qui serait extrêmement
supérieur au reste de la fonction
publique et parfois pour certains
d'entre eux est effectivement supérieure
ou à la rémunération du président de la
république
donc là encore je je pense que d'abord
il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
appelle la haute ou république et qu'on
se rende compte des proportions serre ça
représente un tout petit nombre de
fonctionnaires dans certains cas de
figure ça correspond aussi à des postes
pour lesquels on a voulu je pense en
particulier aux postes qui sont en lien
avec les finances publiques par exemple
les trésoriers payeurs généraux sont
historiquement très bien payés c'est
aussi pour protéger l'intégrité de la
fonction c'est à dire que sont des gens
qui gèrent les finances publiques et que
l'on a peut-être à tort mais c'est ainsi
qu'on fonctionne et ça c'est dans
beaucoup de pays considéré que les
meilleurs moyens de meilleur moyen de se
prémunir de la tentation d'aller
chercher dans la caisse c'est bah
c'était d'abord de bien les rémunérer
parce que c'était un élément de garantie
de leur intégrité après ce que je trouve
assez étonnant c'est que
finalement ce soit le seuil de la
rémunération du président de la
république lié donnez lui la proposition
oui exor comme si on admettait ce qui
n'était pas forcément évident qu'ils
soient légitimes que le président de la
république et une rémunération quasiment
supérieur à tout débat jeu j'ai été très
surpris j'ai été très surpris
effectivement il ya une forme de
légitimité de 200 mais oui oui disent
que ça n'était pas gagné d'avancé 15
millions c'est génial mais en même temps
par rapport à certains hauts
fonctionnaires qu'on finalement beaucoup
moins de responsabilités il est normal
que c'est normal pardon pardon d'abord
c'est pas qu'ils ont moins de
responsabilités c'est pas des
responsabilités de la nature et après il
faut être honnête aussi le président de
la république moi je ne conteste pas du
tout le niveau de sa rémunération
le président de la république a par
ailleurs mon quotidien des avantages
qu'ils voulaient à l'exercice des
fonctions qui ne sont qui sont pas de
même nature
alors bien sûr le président dary promis
qu'ils les laisseront la république son
récent du temps c'est à dire aucun acte
du président de la république
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'ils
bénéficient d'un régime juridique
particulier que ça
aucun acte du prison la république ne
peut être dissociée de la fonction quand
il se brosse les dents le matin il est
considéré comme président de la
république donc ce qui veut dire que
toute sa vie
je ne sais pas s'il faut s'en réjouir
pour lui ou s'il faut l'envié toute sa
vie est réglée par la fonction qui est
la sienne
heureusement que des hauts
fonctionnaires même très assidus ont par
ailleurs un peu aussi une vie en dehors
bien je passe donc à la sixième place
puisque c'est il ya eu inversion
indexation des retraites sur l'inflation
sur le salaire moyen
alors ça c'est c'est ça a longtemps été
en tête et puis un peu baissé dans le
classement ma faim ça a l'air de
remonter
surtout sur le salaire moyen et
indexation sur le salaire moyen a reçu
plus de propositions sur le salaire
moyen que sur l'inflation
ça a existé labellisation des retraites
sur le salaire mais en fait il ya eu
trois niveaux il ya eu le niveau c'est
est indexé sur le salaire oui le salaire
augmente la retraite moyenne augmente
puis il ya une désindexation la mie sur
l'inflation dans l'idée c'était on
augmente plus vite le salaire que
l'inflation du coût discrètement on
baisse de pouvoir d'achat des retraités
et l'a dernièrement on a fait encore
mieux si je fais dire puisqu'on a
désindexé sur l'inflation la
augmentation les eaux rouvrir 0,3 pour
cent et et l'inflation 0 prend pourtant
c'est une économie de 3 milliards 200
millions d'euros pour les jeunes mais ou
trois fois ils sont perdants mais oui du
coup ça va effectivement ça va très vite
vous les masses sert qu'à 300 milliards
de dépenses de retraite vous revaloriser
pas autant que l'inflation c'est un gain
important en terme d'économie pour
l'aider premier league
en revanche cédé paire de ports d'achat
pour l'arrêter ce que je vais dire c'est
quand même que les retraites normal en
sont indexées sur l'inflation
c'est le gouvernement a fait ce choix là
pour des raisons budgétaires en 2009
2020 de désindexer est la norme et passe
à la norme c'est justement une
indexation sur l'inflation qui
effectivement de différent du salariat
et c'est vrai que l'or est indexé sur le
salaire moyen ça coûterait cher ou pas
ah bah ça et ça coûterait plus cher dans
le sens où il a effectivement lieu
aujourd'hui dans les économies attendues
quand vous regardez les projections de
ce qu'on appelle le conseil
d'orientation des retraites
les gars viennent essentiellement de
sacyr que le niveau des retraites
augmente moins vite que les salaires et
donc en gros les cotisations vont
augmenter plus que les retraites ce que
dire que globalement le taux de
remplissage juste ou pas juste la
réalité c'est que ce n'est pas
transparent sert qu'on pourrait dire on
vise un objectif de taux de remplacement
pour que ce soit soutenable au niveau
des finances et laisser dire
il faut que retraités étant du dernier
salaire là aujourd'hui en fait dans la
dans le fonctionnement on voit que c'est
plutôt beaucoup plus lisse et on voit
moins c'est moins transparents et
peut-être que cette question devrait
être jean marc jancovici cerqueira on
nous passerons à la 5e je voulais faire
une remarque
bête mais mais malheureusement très
désagréable qui est que augmenter ce que
des genres soit d'un côté c'est on
habite la moitié des choses tant qu'on
n'a pas dit qui paient donc aujourd'hui
le système de retraites en france est
assis sur des cotisations retraite pour
l'essentiel donc si on augmente les
retraites on augmente les cotisations
retraite
du coup on augmente le coût de ce qui
est fabriqué en france et ça veut dire
soit que les consommateurs continuent
d'acheter français et payent plus cher
soit qu'on favorise les importations et
à ce moment ce n'est pas une idée très
très bonne pour l'emploi donc enfin non
je jouais chez les deux justement cette
cotisation
je schématise un peu ou alors il par
ailleurs le conseil d'orientation des
retraites je voulais également
il a un objectif à une table sur une
croissance de l'économie française de 2
et demi ou deux et demi pour cent par an
en 2050
ac c'est le carrière non c'est un peu
changé l'interview du couple hallyday
devient le premier quart d'heure 0 au
mieux donc c'est bien ça le problème
ça mérite discussion j'aime mieux que
j'ai en parlera de mon sujet je vous
sers et le co pilote sont des retraites
travaille aussi sur un taux de chômage
de 4 25%
amusons-nous le nombre quoi bon alors
mais cercueil
d'ailleurs faut pas aussi oublier que
les retraités wii party sont la retraite
d'amour ils ont cotisé avant c'est pas
l'argent qu'ils ont tous joué par une
pièce de l'état oui c'est un salaire
différé
oui et deuxièmement quand ils ont un
revenu il utilise pour eux s'appelle de
la consommation et donc il faut tourner
alors je lis l'utilisent pour un
hors-jeu pose une décision qui est un
peu iconoclaste que beaucoup pose est-ce
qu'en france les retraités ont sont
privilégiés pas privilégiée est ce que
les retraités ont un niveau de vie
supérieur aux actifs est ce que ce que
bon c'est vrai que beaucoup de beaucoup
de retraités aide de leurs enfants leurs
petits-enfants
c'est vrai aujourd'hui est ce qu'ils ont
vécu une période plus facile peut-être
professionnellement ou je ne sais pas je
savais pour lequel pour certains oui
leur dû être restés 48 heures par
semaine donc est très loin des 35 heures
voilà tout ça et puis c'est vrai que
souvent dit oui gagnent plus que les
actifs et les retraités d'ailleurs
étaient pas des actifs
oui c'est vrai tissu associatif les
aidants
sélection des super actif sauf qu'on les
paye pourpre est actif il ya certains
actifs qu'on paye pour les actifs qu'ils
par ailleurs six cd pactiv ça serait pas
plus mal mais ça c'est encore un autre
suggère en tout cas le rat ces personnes
là et elle contribue au système global
l'économie donc faut pas aussi oui c'est
vraiment là donc c'est pas juste si on
baisse leur niveau de rémunération ou de
retraite du coup aussi consommeront
moins aussi ils seront peut-être moins
attentifs
alors qu'ils enfants aussi de faire tout
ça c'est un ensemble oui on n'est pas
gagnant sur tous les sujets bornes
nous entrons dans le top 5 plutôt pts 5
les cinq propositions qui arrive en tête
des votes on continue à voter rmc.fr on
en est à combien nous allons voir le
chiffre 93 1714 aux votants ça monte ça
ne s'est pas compliqué rmc.fr vous avez
60 propositions vous en choisissez 30 et
ce sont les 30 propositions de lois
citoyenne que je porterai auprès de tous
les élus de la république jean-jacques
alors pas avant que ce soit 100 milles
là on va essayer de se faire je suis ni
rim bravo bravo dénoue top 5
obligation d'un casier judiciaire vierge
pour être candidat à une élection
arnaud mode alors c'était un engagement
de campagne les manuels macron oui ça a
été débattue au moment de la campagne
présidentielle
d'autres sont ralliés à cette
proposition et c'était dans le projet de
loi pour la confiance dans la vie
politique qui a été discuté puis adopté
sauf qu'évidemment ça a disparu en cours
de route je vais expliquer pourquoi en
septembre 2010 est en fait ça a disparu
parce que c'est une obligation qui
vraisemblablement seraient déclarés
contraires à la constitution
vous qui êtes professeur de droit
constitutionnel simple c'est que exiger
un casier judiciaire vierge comme chaque
fois qu'on met une exigence avant une
candidature
ça veut dire que l'on crée des motifs
dîner
j bilité or être inéligible c'est
restreindre la liberté du citoyen d'être
candidat à une élection est donc le
conseil constitutionnel qui considèrent
que la démocratie repose sur la liberté
du citoyen liberté de voter mais aussi
liberté d'être candidat à une
interprétation qui est toujours très
restrictive des hypothèses
d'inéligibilité
c'est à dire que il estime que si on
restreint trop la capacité à être
candidat à une élection eh bien en fait
on porte atteinte aux principes
démocratiques
alors du coup la solution qui a été
retenue en 2017 à ce concours de
discussion législative
l'idée a été à juste titre soutenu
qu'ils avaient un risque de censure par
le conseil constitutionnel
la solution qui a été retenue c'est de
décider que ça n'est pas le casier
judiciaire dans sa globalité ce que je
rappelle en plus que le casier
judiciaire il ya plusieurs volets un
document cliquez qu'il ya des éléments
qui sont effacées à un moment du casier
judiciaire dont qu'est ce que ça veut
dire casier judiciaire vierge c'est au
moment où on est candidat c'est à dire à
l'instant t où il faut ne jamais avoir
rien eu sur son casier judiciaire a
envoyé sa demande d non ce qui a été
décidé dans la loi sur la confiance dans
la vie politique c'est que certaines
infractions certains délits où certains
crimes alors même d'ailleurs qu'il
n'avait rien à voir avec des questions
élective par exemple des crimes
d'attentats aux moeurs ou de cette
nature était automatiquement une
sanctionnée par une inéligibilité
donc on a trouvé en fait une solution
intermédiaire c'est pas la totalité du
casier judiciaire qui est prise en
compte
on n'exige pas la virginité totale du
casier judiciaire pour tout citoyen qui
voudrait être candidat mais on a ciblé
les infractions les plus graves en
justifiant dans ce cas là et le conseil
constitutionnel a dit que ça passait en
justifiant des biens de leuven
c'est difficilement adoptables c'est
difficilement adoptables
eh bien voilà nous avons des précisions
envoyé pourquoi c'est utile sur
l'émission
non mais c'est vrai et c'est vrai nous
allons passer aux quatre premières et
maintenant je vais rejoindre michel qui
est chef d'entreprise qui a dans les
hauts-de-seine
michel qui va à j'oublié mon micro
pardon
si je vous dis une micro ça va pas
michel bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
alors on a parlé tout à l'heure de
l'importance de la tva oui quand on
parle des gars femmes ont fait un
mélange
oui parce qu'en quatrième position vous
allez voir s'afficher la quatrième voie
là imposition à la source des bénéfices
des grandes entreprises dont les gars
femmes dont les femmes et dans les gars
familia deux styles d'entreprise ya
d'abord bien évidemment microsoft
facebook et google qui n'envoient qui
envoient des factures d'irlande dont pas
de tva ont si bien pour l'irlande que
pour la france
or vous avez amazon et apple qui facture
et qui font de la tva alors on va pas
jouer dans la sémantique des
établissements stables comme disait un
économiste entre l'optimisation fiscale
et la fraude fiscale c'est une feuille
de papier à cigarette
donc ce qui se passe c'est que
actuellement on ne peut pas arriver être
d'accord pas 27 c'est à dire que quand
d'un coup vous voulez déterminer
certaines sont stables vous avez
l'irlande qui perd bien sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés quand vous parlez de
l'allemagne quand vous parlez de
l'allemagne l'allemagne taxer les gars
femme a bien sûr peur que tout d'un coup
on leur taxe les voitures allemandes aux
états unis donc et vous avez google qui
a été attaqué par bercy en déclarant
c'est un établissement stable et le
tribunal administratif de paris a
débouté
merci ce parce qu'ils savent de quoi ils
parlent pourtant vers 6 1 eh bien je
pense que des solutions simples dans le
vide tout ce qu'on pourra pas faire
parce qu'on pourra pas tout accès
mais au moins récupérer la tva pour
toute entreprise qui a un établissement
je rappelle que microsoft qui est un
bureau commercial à 1500 personnes en
france et google 700 personnes donc si
ça ce sont ceux des bureaux de
représentation
ça m'étonne merci pour cette
intervention mathieu plane alors dans ce
havre est un vrai sujet inquiets
deux autres débats et c'est bien qu'ils
soient sur la table en parce que oui
alors il ya une taxe prévue serré dit
que non bon alors c'est ridicule ça
c'est ridicule c'est 500 millions mais
on pourrait faire la la la la la
question c'est comment on identifie le
vrai résultat qui est qui est réalisé
mais en fait c'est des activités qu'on
commun d'être des services numériques en
réalité d'où la difficulté à identifier
les opérations et surtout la facilité à
délocaliser l'origine du chiffre
d'affaires quoi donc à une différence
entre l'utilisation est l'outil
producteurs qui peut être facilement
délocaliser c'est vrai que tout vous
revenez souvent des questions
européennes 1 c'est à dire que la
voiture on a battu une hélistation aussi
européennes et qu'on n'a pas réussi à
mettre en commun ce qui aurait été comme
une force de frappe c'est la possibilité
de taxer au niveau européen sa logique
puisqu'on va entrer dans les élections
européennes et le sait on a un problème
c'est que sur les questions fiscales il
faut l'unanimité au niveau européen il
faut les limiter
l'unanimité est donc 7 28 et cette
proposition a été avancée et d'avancer
la france était notamment c'est
intéressant ce que la france a plutôt
est très actif sur ce sujet là mais bien
sûr l'irlande a refusé l'irlande a des
intérêts très fort en fait et vécu
je sais qu est la suède et le danemark
il ya aussi l'allemagne et pour d'autres
raisons c'est qu'ils ont peur de se
prendre des états unis et du tax
l'industrie automobile voyez donc que
y'a les représailles et ses dix
émissions d'intérêt qui sont bruns comme
un média aussi qu'un millier d'autres
pays que l'irlande qui en europe en
europe ne sont pas des paradis fiscaux
mais presque
le luxembourg malte les pays bas les
pays bas tu souhaites livre aussi ses
importantes pour ce type d'opération est
donc c'est vrai que cette question là
peut être assez révoltante dans le sens
où c'est des groupes qui ont qu'elles
ont plus de puissants et les et
l'imaginons que nous ne soyons plus dans
l'union européenne
imaginons imaginons parce que certains
gisent morts se défendre vous n'imaginez
pas mais certains défendent
minoritaire on est bien d'accord je vais
imaginons que nous soyons seul
est ce que nous voyons à ses joueurs les
gars je bats imaginer ça c'est bon c'est
d'un compliqué sur ce que ça
entraînerait donc oui ça ça devient si
vous avez géré par complet plus non mais
donc du coup la question c'est au niveau
rouge donc la france qu'elle commence
justement à dire bah on va le faire et
on va s intéressant chez plus royaume
uni en parler il faut que l'allemagne
est aussi quoi et que si les gros
européen le front alors à ce moment là
il faut finalement forcé d'une façon ou
d'une autre les petits accepter ça et
c'est vrai que sur le consentement à
l'impôt se pose ce problème l'aserc une
pme locale va quatre ans michel ces
grands groupes ne désire et je pense que
c'est le coeur du sujet oui il sera
impossible de regarder dans les
résultats justement je serai dans le
dans l'internet dont je connais bien le
sujet ce que je veux dire il sera
impossible de trouver un accord avec les
27 pays avec l'établissement ce talent
je veux dire simplement en tant
qu'entreprise quand vous recevez une
facture d'amazon ou une facture de
google il y à une tva quand vous avez
google qui ne met pas tva la facture
viennent d'irlande en comptabilité un
jeu pas trop compliqué on fait une
opération neutre
on passe comme si on avait payé de la
tva et on la remet ce qui fait une
opération à 0 ok mais ni la france ni
l'irlande n'a récupéré de la tva
donc il suffirait simplement je parle
pas des résultats d'impôt sur les
sociétés je parle simplement de la tva
quand on reçoit on reçoit toutes
factures dans une entreprise il faut
qu'elle porte la tva et si c'est pas
l'irlande qui va la récupérer donc on la
récupère nour et au niveau des
entreprises et on la paye
l'administration fiscale ces quelques
milliards jacques ménard et ses frères
voilà belle démonstration non belle
démonstration
donc on va essayer d'aller plus loin que
baisser le salaire des députés
mais c'est vrai que si ces quelques
milliards oui mais c'est quand même très
bon à prendre
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui parce que sur
le chiffre d'affaires on va déjà de 500
millions sur 3 pour 30 du chiffre
d'affaires donc toujours milliards c'est
quand même un choc important et c'est
vrai qu'il faudrait pas passer à côté
quoi 3 milliards c'est un peu comme
celle de serge gayral les faits on est
passé à 94 1450 si vous votez sur les
écuries et 21h30
6 nous allons passer aux trois premières
en troisième position la prise en compte
du vote blanc est validé l'élection si
le vote blanc est majoritaire à nos
vallées d'élections si le vote blanc est
majoritaire alors d'abord la première
question qui se pose c'est la prise en
compte du vote blanc dans quels cas est
ce que ces noms tout l'écart parce que
le vote blanc on peut le prendre en
compte pour les élections quelqu'un on
estime qu aucun des candidats qui se
présentent les satisfaisant et donc on
décide de manifester sa désapprobation
en votant blanc peut aussi faire à
l'occasion d'un référendum
on parle de référendum même si j'ai
compris que ce n'est pas dans le top 10
et là j'ai été grande surprise ce n'est
pas dans le top 30 même même à mais même
pas dans le top 30 un homme sérieux les
différents c'est dingue sur le
référendum est fier beaucoup moins de
désir de référendum
c'est dans les 60 propositions mais
c'est pas dans les 30 dans la prise en
compte du vote blanc
oui voilà pour quel scrutin tous les
scrutins pas tous les temps et c'est là
peut prendre en compte ça veut dire
qu'on est des comptes dans les suffrages
exprimés parce qu'aujourd'hui
là encore depuis une loi de 2014 le vote
blanc est comptabilisé avant mon mélange
et le blanc et le nul serre on était une
enveloppe
id ce qui est un vote blanc ou ont
déchiré où on faisait je ne sais quel
signe sur un bulletin de vote c'est est
décompté ensemble en 2014 on a dit c'est
que le vote blanc avait une
particularité donc on a décidé de le
décompte et au moment où on fait le
dépouillement mais il ne rentre pas dans
ce qu'on appelle les suffrages exprimés
serre qu'il est visible quand on
proclame les résultats
comme le vote mais une cloche là alors
pourquoi pour une raison simple c'est
que l'objectif d'une élection et d'élire
quelqu'un et que donc l'objectif de
l'élection et de se baser sur ce qu'ils
expriment un choix or le vote blanc par
définition c'est quand même le rejet de
tous les choix
bon c'est aussi un choix c'est un choix
de rejeter les jours impairs l'opinion
politique c'est le sujet de toutes les
époques discuter des excuses mais refuse
le choix qu'on propose un contenu alors
non mais j'entends bien les deux
arguments je vous explique juste et
raison pour you est le sixième d'une
soul est aujourd'hui est celui là est la
vraie difficulté que ça pose mais je
vais donner un autre exemple d'ailleurs
la vraie difficulté que ça pose c'est
que si on a validé l'élection lorsque le
vote blanc est majoritaire lors d'abord
un détail majoritaire ça veut dire quoi
est-ce qu'il ya plus de blancs que deux
voies à porter à quiconque si vous avez
trois candidats et des votes blancs vous
pouvez avoir le blanc en tête parce
qu'il aura 31 des voix
ou est ce qu on est sur une la majorité
absolue si on a plus de 50% des voix
requis se porte sur le vote blanc
effectivement on peut considérer qu'il
ya un problème c'est un sujet qui a été
à sous l'angle du vote blanc mais c'est
un sujet qui parfois est abordée
lorsqu'on évoque l'abstention exemple
dans certains pays en italie quand il y
a plus d' abstention plus de 50% des
électeurs qui ne se déplace pas un
scrutin
on valide le scrutin le valais ne prenez
par exemple au référendum sur le
quinquennat en france 70% nuit mais 70%
d'abstention donc ça veut dire que le
référendum sur le quinquennat
si l'on avait été en italie aurait été
invalidés alors on peut dire ça
n'intéresse pas les gens donc finalement
c'est pas un sujet on supprime les
auteurs je rappelle juste un élément
très que invalider les élections ça peut
sembler
sympathique j'allais bien on peut dire
ce formidable on est contre et ça ça un
coup puisque l'on parle beaucoup de
questions financières rappelle qu
organiser une élection ça coûte quelques
millions d'euros et que quand c'est pas
quelques dizaines de millions dans
surtout qu'il faut comptabiliser
l'argent des campagnes électorales en
ami et donc se dire parce qu'il ya plus
de votes blancs que deux votes positifs
en faveur de quelque chose on recommence
tout ça risque de durer longtemps et
donc ça peut aussi à un moment donné
entre mu et les nerfs des électeurs et
des candidats mais ça vous dirait c'est
pas très grave mais quand même aussi
représenter un coût pour la démocratie
sûrement que le seuil en plus pendant ce
temps l'un des objets de garder les
mêmes c'est comme un symbole les votes
blancs arrive devant la presse que les
gens qui se présentent ne nous satisfont
pas
on était quand même en terme de deux
logiques ont validé une élection chaque
citoyen peut aussi ni même se présentait
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière le
débat autour des gilet jaune
oui à un moment donné a tourné autour de
ça c'est à dire les gilet jaune conteste
les institutions les solutions les
politiques etc et donc beaucoup de gens
j'allais dire résonnant selon les canons
habituels de la démocratie disent ils
font qu'il présente une liste et
qu'effectivement il rentre dans le jeu
politique s'ils ont des propositions
alternatives à faire aux femmes sexy à
un moment donné tout le monde est contre
tous mais personne ne propose rien si
c'est vrai que le semi-marathon l'aréna
dessous le second tour de la
présidentielle poserait beaucoup de
problèmes que c'est à dire qu'on
pourrait alors d'enseignement se
retrouver avec quelqu'un qui ait enfin
un président dans une prison qui n'est
pas la majorité
moi j'ai eu des us gerba tout petit
amendement qui concerne votre profession
on pourrait systématiquement aux
résultats des élections donner de
décompte
juste les suffrages exprimés ce qui en
général ce qu'on nous sert et ramener ça
aux gens qui ont voté ce qui est une
façon de prendre en compte le vote blanc
au moins dans la présentation des
résultats
oui hein
et c'est vrai c'est exceptionnel je suis
assez d'accord
je suis assez d'accord on est en haut on
ne donne pas le nombre de votes blancs
très rarement et on donne pas du quick
je suis dit on va dire qu'on vient
d'avoir 51% des suffrages exprimés
on se rendrait compte en fait c'est 40 %
des votants
[Musique]
c'est un choix mais chaud jus cette
conscience de sa vie s'en sont une
information qui est intéressant dans
j'entends mais vous savez comme moi que
c'est ce qu'on retiendra et même si on
va encore plus loin on peut même
réintégrer ceux qui se sont abstenus et
dire alors là c'est plus que là je parle
juste de votants l'informateur dans
l'exil le débat est ouvert
si on met l'abstention est certain en
2010 elles sont utilisées savoir c'est
bien bien ça serait une prime aux gens
qui se sont déplacés qui ont dit pour
jouer rien de me tente vraiment et je ne
dis pas qu'il faut rebâtir et tout le
temps je dis le fait de donner cette
information à un moment et quand même
quelque chose d'un peu aucun histoire
17%
je trouve que ça si a passé un composant
de gens qui se déplacent ça me paraît
assez intéressant de dire ça groupe a
par exemple prenez les élections
européennes il trompait n'y pense pas
forcément absurde de considérer qu'on
peut la fixer au site
alors là aussi on retombe sur un autre
problème pardon je la sais que certains
disent il faut rendre le vote
obligatoire là encore en france on a
fait un choix historique depuis la
révolution française nous sommes dans
une logique de vote facultatif
c'est-à-dire que chaque citoyen son âme
et conscience au jour de l'élection
décide s'il veut prendre part à la
décision collective ou rester chez lui
personne ne va sonder les reins et les
coeurs pour savoir les raisons pour
quelle il est resté chez lui donc à
partir du moment où on est sur un vote
facultatif ça veut dire qu'on part du
principe que si un beau jour il ya très
peu de gens qui se déplacent et bah
finalement c'est la liberté de
l'électeur
voyez que votre blanc nombre minimum de
votants et c'est ça nous rapproche d'une
tendance qui est culturellement et
politiquement pas la note c'est à dire
celle du vote obligatoire c'est tout ça
c'est des choix avec derrière
avant d'aider des conséquences sur
georges bérard qu'on pourrait faire un
lien avec tout ce qui a été dit on
pourrait décider que s'il ya moins de 50
% le salaire des députés est divisé par
deux pics sur moi comme ça on retrouve
un peu tout le monde
95100 25 votants 4 mais c'est rohff
mini-messages rmc.fr donc propreté 95100
25 votants
allez les deux premières maintenant fin
en deuxième position en fin des
avantages pour les anciens présidents et
premiers c'est en moi il ya beaucoup
d'instituts et en même temps même temps
c'est pas vraiment d'institutionnels
c'est 7 6 et 6 me demande c'est une
demande est extrêmement forte et
extrêmement on a beaucoup parlé on a
beaucoup parlé du secrétariat de la
sécurité des présidents auraient pu
aussi des premiers ministres alors il
faut bien faire la différence en sont
nombreux en ville et premier ministre
encore mais ils sont nombreux
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie on
voit bien oui et comme ça vous faisant
plus jeune élue forcément ils vont
rester et très longtemps oui faut
d'abord bien distinguer les trois cas de
figure où les ministres soyons clairs
les anciens ministres n'ont aucun
avantage
bon aucun le régime c'est celui du
paiement pendant les trois mois qui
suivent la fin de leur fonction s'ils
n'ont pas d'autres rémunérations s'ils
n'ont pas retrouvé un travail de leurs
indemnités ministre est au bout de trois
mois
sa tombe est derrière les seuls
ministres qui par tradition j'allais
dire ont parfois des avantages notamment
en termes de chauffeurs et serra sont
plutôt les ministres de l'intérieur
le cas échéant certains garde des sceaux
mais quasiment plus aujourd'hui on est
plus en plus qu'un chauffeur aux
chauffeurs sécurité c'est un peu normal
aussi mais non plus que ça le met les
intérieurs sont ça dépend ce faux pas
alors au fantasme et là dessus ah bon
d'abord il faut aussi rappeler comme
pour tous n'a là pour le coup jusqu'en
on était dans l'opacité la plus complète
c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait pas
deux règles du jeu qui a été clairement
fixée à part une c'est que je crois que
c'est un texte de 1900 début des années
60 que la retraite d'ancien président de
la république était indexée sur la
retraite des conseillers d'état c'est à
dire à peu près 5000 500 euros nets
quelque chose comme ça comme retraite
après il ya toute une série davantage
qui à un moment donné se sont ajoutés à
tout cela comme d'ailleurs la
rémunération du chef d'état pendant très
longtemps la rémunération du chef d'état
ait été déterminé on ne savait pas
commencé en 2008 qu'on décide de la
fixées par la loi alors pour les anciens
présidents de la république
les choses ont été clarifiées par un
décret de 2016 donc d'abord il y a le
fait que les anciens présidents de la
république sont membres de droit du
conseil constitutionnel
ce qui veut dire que s'il décide d'y
siéger ils sont rémunérés en tant que
membre du conseil qu'on sait plus
combien 4000 euros combien 14000 euros
s'ils n'y vont pas s'il n'y siège pas et
aujourd'hui à par valéry giscard
d'estaing plus aucun ancien président de
la république ni va ils ne sont pas
rémunérés
donc ça ça n'est pas arrivé les 14000
euros sont cumulées avec avec leur
retraite avec l'horreur est dedans siens
en deuxième
oui mais attendez pour une seule once
est un vrai job oui oui c'est un vrai
job
oui non mais je sais pas si c'est pas
juste que je pose de conscient comme
cela juste la présence nos jours de la
réunion et envoyé un peu de travail en
amont d'autant que le conseil a une
toute petite structure mais ça c'est un
autre un autre débat donc ça ça n'est
pas un avantage des anciens présents à
cully qui se trouve que la constitution
a prévu depuis 1958 que les anciens
présidents et est membre de droit du
conseil
encore une fois s'il n'y vont pas dans
d'autres pays on a fixé des règles par
exemple en italie les anciens présidents
de la république sont automatiquement
sénateur à vie
d'accord voilà il ya des usages
un état à l'autre telli sièges et un
siège mais en tout cas commis son
sénateur à vie pour le coup même s'il ne
siège pas de manière effective eux
peuvent toucher lorsqu'après bon voilà
chaque et à trouver des solutions pour
récompenser ceux qui ont assiégé japon
les présidents italiens le deuxième
deuxième élément la retraite je le
disais qui est touché à l'âge de la
retraite c'est à dire dès qu'on a fini
son mandat de président on bénéficie pas
de la retraite
on est bien dans le cadre du régime des
retraites et puis par ailleurs
effectivement il ya des avantages et le
décrète 2016 a mis en place un système
dégressif c'est à dire que pendant cinq
ans après le mandat les anciens
présidents de la république bénéficie de
mise à disposition de personnel
véhicules locaux etc
et au bout de cinq ans le décret prévoit
un système de dégressivité donc moins de
personnel extérieur etc ça donc ça ça a
été cadré pour la première fois on peut
encore le contester mais objectivement
il ya déjà beaucoup de mieux par rapport
à ce qui existait auparavant
les anciens premiers ministres là c'est
différent puisque les anciens premiers
ministres bénéficient eux ils sont des
ministres comme les autres d'aucune
retraite on tombe enfin donc un régime
par don de 2 d'année en attendant il ya
une tradition de mise à disposition de
locaux et de personnel qui la font
l'objet aussi depuis 2016 d'une
réglementation plus clair encore une
fois l'idée c'était plus d'être dans des
usages
sauf qu'évidemment les noms qui sont
prises en plus nombreux les anciens
présidents aussi bon chocolat
est-ce que c'est ces avantages peuvent
être réduits ou pas car je sais pas ce
qu'ils doivent être réduits est-ce que
c'est très important
financièrement c'est financièrement
c'est pas le coup je le soutiens
symbolique
olic et en même temps et les privilégiés
qui ont exercé son guide à 7 8 10
personnes
pendant cinq ans il a droit à cette
salle on passe à trois réformes
d'accord on va alors on va finir avec la
première c'est ce que nous allons faire
on va la garder pour après la pub
allez un petit stand non je veux faire
un point sur les votants 95 1607
nous allons découvrir la première
compétition qui arrive en tête et
ensuite nous allons passer à d'autres
propositions qui sont dans les 30
parce que là on a donné dix neuf pour
l'instant on va donner 10 et ensuite
dont pouvez vous allez voir sur
l'environnement l'écologie
il ya plein de choses sur le glyphosate
la taxation des carburants maritime
enfin bon l'incitation fret ferroviaire
la mise en place d'une vignette poids
lourds enfin bon tout cela on en parlait
avec jean marc jancovici nous parlerons
aussi d'autres propositions
par exemple redonner à l'état la gestion
des autoroutes ça c'était de ça revient
régulièrement ça coûterait une fortune
mais bon ça revient la suppression de l'
aime aussi qui est l'une des
propositions en parlait la fiscalité
l'économie suppression des droits de
succession sauf pour les plus hauts
patrimoines
allocations familiales dès le premier
enfant est limitée à trois enfants
paiement de l'impôt sur le revenu ne dès
le premier euro gagnaire va tout cela on
va en parler et puis nous allons parler
aussi d'autres propositions sur les
institutions réduction du nombre de
parlementaires dose de proportionnelle
enfin nous ne parlerons pas peut-être un
mot à la fin du référendum de la
suppression de l' isf et de la
légalisation du cannabis
voilà trois propositions qui ne sont pas
dans les 30 voulue par les auditeurs de
rmc les téléspectateurs drm ces
découvertes ce qui surprend tout le
monde
mais bon le premier j'étais surpris lisf
banon fatalement demandé la suppression
de l'ieseg curieusement et le référendum
va curieusement ou pas rétablissement
pardon de l'île saint-louis à
suppression c'est fait et le référendum
non plus ni référendum révocatoire ni
référendum abrogatoire lee baho 4,95
1607 votants il est 21h52 on se retrouve
dans quelques mois
moi en fait
[Musique]
rien n'est impossible votre 30
rien n'est impossible votre proposition
de loi citoyenne nous avons découvert
les neuf premières n'ont pas les neuf
premières du numéro deux au numéro 10 et
maintenant la première proposition qui
arrive en tête des 30 propositions qui
se dégage vous rappelle que vous avez 60
propositions vous allez sur le site
rmc.fr et vous allez dégagez 30
propositions de lois citoyenne que je
porterai devant tous les élus de la
république en tête donc avec 50 de 1407
votants la revalorisation des salaires
des enseignants et nous sommes avec
présentez-vous catherine gauthrin
ouverte en la première fois de ma vie je
crois que suis en première position
quelque part j'ai su professeurs des
écoles effectivement depuis 25 ans en
zep en région parisienne et s'affairait
dont 25 ans est donc une bonne dizaine
de ministres un que j'ai vu passer et
toujours avec le même mot l'éducation
qui est au centre
presque une priorité la priorité
l'éducation est donc toujours avec d une
belle preuve d'amour pour les
enseignants enfin une belle déclaration
d'amour moi ce que je veux c'est une
preuve d'amour et les preuves d'amour ça
commence déjà par la reconnaissance et
puis la reconnaissance est aussi la
revalorisation des salaires et l'entrée
dans le métier chez nous c'est assez
compliqué parce qu'on est les jeunes
instit que vraiment que j'admire ils
sont à bac +5 et rentre dans le métier à
1500 euros par mois
et au bout de 15 ans à peu près à mener
à 2200 euros net par mois
donc par rapport aux autres catégories
ad à fonction publique
on est quand même bien bien en retrait
et comme une mauvaise moment depuis
trois mois et c'est la justice en ya la
justice sociale et la justice fiscale il
ya aussi la justice salariale
moi je crois qu'on n'a pas on vole pas
notre notre métier on fait le boulot on
le fait bien on le fait passionnément et
combien gagnez-vous quatre aides
moi je gagne de 1300 euros net par mois
2300 euros
oui bien danet
25 ans d'éducation nationale 25 ans je
me plains pas je me plains pas assez
c'est surtout pour les pour les jeunes
qui je crois je suis à clichy c'est pour
les jeunes qui rentrent dans le métier
parce que c'est véritablement
l'éducation on dit que c'est important
avec tout ce qui se passe en ce moment
mardi dernier encore il y avait ce
mouvement contre l'antisémitisme et sur
chaque plateau on entendait l'éducation
l'école que fait l'école quand il ya eu
les attentats en 2015 c'était café
l'école le chômage qui a fait l'école
que fait l'école pour avoir débré des
bons professeurs des écoles
il faut avoir une formation qui est à la
hauteur et on on est des gens on fait
tout ce qu'on peut du mieux qu'on peut
alors cette justice là je crois que elle
est légitime je crois que c'est pas
aberrant c'est pas indécent chopra pas
quelle question avez vous envie de poser
à nos experts j'ai pas j'ai pas
tellement les pas question j'ai pas de
question je vous avais le ministre face
à vous que l'une d'elles si j'avais
mieux j
les paroles c'est bien les actes c'est
mieux présenter nos miroirs soir j'ai
entendu c'est bien non c'est ici c'est
très bien mais eux toujours le même
discours ça fait trente ans on va
essayer en cinq ans ça sera mieux mais
faites-le maintenant quand j'ai vu qu'il
y avait certaines propositions les
heures supplémentaires
augmenter le nombre d'heures
supplémentaires non peut nous le
professeur des écoles alors si ces
sites-là délicat des écoles oncle en
région parisienne par exemple le fait
les études le soir on peut avoir des
erreurs des heures supplémentaires mais
c'est pareil
les instituteurs en ruralité non pas les
études
donc ça peut être des fois 100 200 300
peut même aller jusqu'à 400 euros par
mois au plus et là aussi il ya une
injustice on fait le même métier qu'on
soit à guingamp ou à nîmes on fait le
même métier ou à paris on fait le même
métier et il y à des disparités de
salaire si on fait le même métier
si si non parce que je pense que ce
n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
pourquoi serge
parce que les publics sont pas
nécessairement les mêmes et c'est pas
pareil d'être jeu est caricaturé dans le
16e arrondissement est d'être dans
certains quartiers c'est pas pareil de
pas voir aucun accès par exemple à
d'autres à des musées les éléments comme
ça quand on est très très loin avoir des
preuves de déplacements par an pour
emmener les enfants à aller voir un
musée des choses comme ça quand on est
très loin que quand on est dans une
ville dont il ya aussi quand même des
différences c'est le même métier dans la
volonté mais après dans la situation
parfois ça peut être assez sur ce coup
bien merci catherine merci c'est la
première proposition qui est en tête
la revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants mathieu plane à bâle en tête
c'est qu'il ya des raisons et
mais alors ça rejoint ce qu'on disait
peut-être tout à l'heure avec la
fonction publique hospitalière
ce ce sont des des des fonctionnaires
qui est donc temps on connaît la valeur
et que que compensent mal payés pas
suffisamment payés parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup de mérite d'abord parce qu'ils
sont proches de nous non alors c'est
vrai que et et ensuite on s'identifie à
eux et on a besoin d'eux on a besoin de
ces investissements dans l'avenir
important donc c'est vrai on peut penser
que le salaire fait pas tout mais je
pensais quand même quelque chose
d'important et c'est une forme de
reconnaissance donc la question qui se
pose c'est effectivement ça fait presque
dix ans qui a eu très peu de
revalorisation d'un doublé son public
différentes raisons mais c'est vrai
quand on fait les comparaisons
internationales
pour le coup la france se place très mal
dans leur rémunération des enseignants
notamment dans le primaire on est très
bas on est presque en bas de l'échelle
de l' ocde on est par exemple primaires
c'est quasiment deux fois moins qu'en
allemagne c'est à dire catherine en
allemagne ce dernier serait autour de
4000 je pense aux deux faussaires que
yahia dont et donc c'est vrai que cette
question se pose là dessus alors on a
une dépense d'éducation pourtant qui est
assez élevé mais pour d'autres raisons
et notamment parce qu'on a beaucoup
d'enfants pas besoin d'autres pays donc
forcément au cous et d'envoyer puis fond
vous allez dépenser bon mais la dépense
par élève est pas très élevé et surtout
ce qui attribuer aux rémunérations des
enseignants est assez faible par contre
il ya d'autres choses sur nous sur la
dépense d'éducation nationale savez tous
les services annexes
'cela va être la cantine c'est le
transport scolaire que d'autres n'ont
pas mais par contre là la rémunération
des enseignants c'est un vrai débat
aujourd'hui l'allemagne et la france est
vraiment en bas de classement et cette
question peut se poser sur après au delà
ça vous avez par des jeunes mais je
pense que l'attractivité du métier et la
question pour le future salle si vous
voulez avoir aussi des enseignants qui
sont de qualité faut aussi être capable
de les attirer parce que sinon les
arbitrages qui sont dans votre vie est
effectivement aujourd'hui les conditions
de travail sont pas toujours évidentes
et surtout il ya aussi autre chose par
rapport aux autres pays c'est qu'il ya
plus d'élèves par professeur en france
que dans les autres pays
certains cas sont quand même très
remplie quoi donc le coût par élève est
assez faible et donc cette question là
doit être déposée bien oui
catherine
ce matin je me précipite catherine david
18 à jouer ce jeu par les alizés qui
choses plus le gel du point d'indicé
depuis 2010 ce qui a plu mais nous on
vérifie les enseignants sa plombé depuis
2010 il ya eu peut-être en 2016 ou 2017
elle ça a plombé le le moi j'ai déjà
j'ai un collègue ya deux ou trois ans
jeune instit qui dormait dans sa voiture
il se doucher à l'école donc première
proposition qui arrive en tête pour
l'instant en est à combien de votants 96
et 8 132 96 1800 et aurait on y arrive
rien et moi y arriver c'est quand même
super bon signe oui je trouve que les
gens qui répondent il pense d'abord aux
enseignants terre mais bien aussi alors
en fait je suis sur la même chose de
fort et depuis le début je suis surpris
par ces résultats c'est c'est finalement
assez positive à ce gang et c5 et rennes
se sont oui il n'ya pas que des râleurs
et il ya aussi des hommes des femmes des
français qui veulent construire qui
veulent faire avancer les choses
alors regardons environnement écologie
puisque maintenant nous allons nous
avons eu les dix premières mais derrière
les faux mais à un art vin puisque je
vous rappelle que j'emporterais 30 il y
en a 20 qui sont pas loin en nombre de
votes l'environnement l'écologie la fin
du glyphosate d'ici trois ans et
l'accélération de la transition des
agriculteurs vers le bio alors c est
rigolo parce que je sors du salon de
l'agriculture jusqu'à aujourd'hui où
j'avais jean marc jancovici j'ai été
discuté avec un représentant d'une
organisation syndicale agricole alors
l'agriculture en fait elle est
aujourd'hui héritière d'une longue
histoire qui a démarré
soit quelques siècles soit dans l'après
guerre il faut savoir que dans
l'immédiate après guerre il y avait
encore un tiers de la population active
qui était dans l'agriculture un tiers un
tiers
beaucoup aujourd'hui sert aujourd'hui
5,3 et demi 4 % voient rigoler 2% 2
qu'on semble chaque jour après jour ça
diminue et dans le même temps le prix
réel de la nourriture a été divisée par
n'importe pas entre 5 et 10 donc en fait
les agriculteurs d'aujourd'hui ils sont
devenus des formidablement aidé par
l'énergie abondante à tous les étages
pour faire avancer les tracteurs et tous
les engins agricoles 1 pour transporter
un tout ce qu'ils produisent si on a
réussi à vider les campagnes et à mettre
tout le monde en ville c'est parce que
vous avez un camion sur trois en france
qui transporte quelque chose qui se
mange non donc vous avez une dépendance
aux transports à laval et donc au
pétrole à laval qui est absolument
massive
ils ont également été aidé par les
engrais qui sont fabriqués et du gaz
naturel
il faut le rappeler c'est la chimie de
la bagna quelques est naturelle et enfin
par les phytosanitaires
donc en fait ils ont eu toutes ces aides
mais qui se paye toutes plus ou moins
cher d'une certaine manière alors il ya
une première chose qu'on paye c'est que
les campagnes j'en étais désertique et
ce qui est pas nécessairement une très
bonne idée dans l'absolu la deuxième
chose qu'on paye assez que effectivement
maintenant mais des phytosanitaires
partout parce que ça remplace les
ouvriers qui désherber et si on veut
faire le chemin inverse
il faut remettre les ouvriers pour
désherber c'est le même prix donc on a
un arbitrage en ce moment entre oui
c'est exactement ça c'est un bol de
vases communicants à 6 millions de
chômeurs oui mais si on les met dans
l'agriculture qui serait une sur le
papier une très bonne idée à ce moment
il faut accepter de payer le prix de la
nourriture plus de manière plus élevé
alors vous pouvez avoir des voies de
contournement
vous pourrez faire des circuits plus
courts mais du coup ça veut dire que
vous avez moins de monde dans la grande
distribution enfin bref tout ça tout ça
est un jeu de mikado cette aspiration
oui il nourriture
le bio la fin du glyphosate mon avis
personnel c'est que dans le monde qui
s'annonce on a tout intérêt à remettre
du monde de l'agriculture a augmenté la
valeur ajoutée qui va dans les
exploitations par exemple transformer le
lait en yaourt directement à la ferme on
est de vendre son l'air un collègue
bordelais qui va vous l'achetez pas cher
on a intérêt du coup à accepter nous les
consommateurs qu'on va manger moins de
ce qui vaut cher
typiquement la viande mais que l'éleveur
où l'agriculteur touchera une part plus
importante de ce qu'on paye et puis on
devrait accepter à ce moment qu'une
partie des emplois qui sont aujourd'hui
dans la grande distribution
oui et dans les gros de
l'agroalimentaire se déplacent ailleurs
et c'est un truc qu'on va pas faire en
une semaine mais il faut le faire oui la
maison du territoire derrière et on va
encourager les circuits courts et les a
encouragés entre autres choses plus de
circuits courts
évidemment évidemment mais devra
continuer de faire du vin de bordeaux à
bordeaux a partout en france
[Rires]
97000 0,46 taxation des carburants
maritimes et aériens alors attention la
compétitivité économique nous disent
ceux qui sont contre et oui moi je suis
tout à fait pour mais ça pose un
problème pratique qui est qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez une convention internationale
qui vous dit que le kérosène n'est pas
taxée donc il faut juste défaire cette
convention les solutions de chicago je
croise avec une convention humaine très
bien défaire de toute convention humaine
peut être des restes par les hommes mais
c'est encore pire que l'europe puis
trois sets ça dépend de si je prends
l'avant après mars
il faut se mettre d'accord a beaucoup il
ya des gens qui on proposait déjà de
commencer par la taxe et sur les vols
intérieurs
oui enfin en france en vol intérieur il
nous reste paris toulouse on pérennise
et paris-nice absolument se renforcer
paris marseille il a neigé 80% bon mise
en place d'une vignette poids lourds à
la fois pour les transporteurs français
et étrangers ça va faire hurler c'était
le transport routier
les quotas oui c'est le caprice à un
milliard de madame je ne nommerai pas
alors il faut savoir que le transport
routier est un métier à très faibles
marges s'il ya des transporteurs qui
nous écoutent donc en fait ce genre dès
que vous voulez monter le prix du
transport routier pour faire payer la
pollution du transport routier
il faut obligatoirement le répercuter
sur ce qu'on appelle les chargeurs c'est
à dire les gens qui donnent les
marchandises à transporter ah oui c'est
obligatoire donc sur le consommateur en
bout de course qui va payer plus jamais
un moment c'est toujours de tous les
jours mais c'est un choix collectif en
fait c'est un choix que l'essayer c'est
à dire ayant d'ailleurs l'environnement
c'est une adhésion collective exactement
c'est très intéressant dans les
questions qui sont posées
oui finalement c'est à quelle
contrepartie on est prêt à mettre 100
c'est tout une affaire de contreparties
dont catherine trois parties on est on
veut vendre ils auraient à faire ça oui
cc je réduis l'écologie exactement
donc la vigne et de poids lourd alors la
vignette d'une manière générale sur tous
les véhicules qui consomment du pétrole
sera une bonne idée parce que pour
mettre la casquette de tristes sires il
faut savoir que le pétrole n'est pas
éternelle climat ou pas climat que
depuis 2006 l'approvisionnement
pétrolier de l'europe décline en temps
dans ce cas il est reparti à la hausse
quelques années grâce au pétrole de
schiste va repartir dans l'autre sens
donc de toute façon il va falloir
organiser la société avec de moins en
moins de pétrole
de toute façon et donc il faut amortir
cette chose là dans la durée donc tout
mécanisme qui permet de la morte hier
dans la durée et bien mieux que toute
crise brutale bien nous alors on je
retourne dans le public parce que
guillaume a lui aussi une proposition à
défendre bonsoir guillaume priante
présentez vous alors donc je suis idiome
je suis conducteur de train j'habite en
bretagne et moi je veux défendre donc
forcément le fret ferroviaire en france
qui n'aurait fait de baisser depuis dont
les trente ans et c'est l'une des
propositions incitation au fret
ferroviaire bonus malus pour les
entreprises en fonction du taux de
marchandises transportées par rail faut
regarder alors le transport par rail
puisque vous êtes dans le dans le
système ferroviaire vous savez qu'en
fait historiquement il était surtout
consul pour les pondéreux c'est à dire
les choses qui pèsent lourd
le bois les
real le charbon le ciment en vrac et
c'est qu'ils allaient d'un point donné à
un autre temps donné puis toujours le
même donc toujours du bassin serré des
silos par exemple d'entreposage des
céréales vers le port on les exportent
ouvert l'usiné où on transforme
aujourd'hui qu'on a essentiellement des
endroits où on produit des produits
manufacturés en petites quantités en
fait ce système de transport ils
demandent à être complétée par du camion
c'est là qu'il faut aller mettre du
camion à l'amont mettre ça dans des
wagons faire un train qui va jusqu'à un
endroit où des groupes pour redistribuer
derrière dire via le transport de
combinés qui est absolument absolument
très simple et alors elle ce week end
avec lesquels de combiner c'est une
pièce mobile qui va sur camion comme sur
tout sur trois il faut des camions avant
et après alors c'est juste en train
d'expliquer le système est là et le fait
qu'il ya eu une contraction naturel
d'une grosse partie du fret ferroviaire
parce que c'était le fret de matériaux
pondéreux y avait des endroits où ils
résistent très bien pour une très
mauvaise raison par exemple les états
unis le fret ferroviaire résiste très
bien pour transporter le charbon est pas
si c'était une très bonne idée
donc j'espère finir donc le combiné des
choses à dire le combiné est quelque
chose qu'il peut effectivement
représenter une fraction plus importante
que ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui il ya une
petite rupture de charge parce qu'il
faut prendre la caisse sur le camion la
mettre sur le train etc
et après vous avez un deuxième problème
sur les infrastructures c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a favorisé en france
des infrastructures ferroviaires pour
transporter des passagers
et vous avez un engorgement sur les
sillons quand vous voulez faire passer
des trains de fret
alors tout ça est soluble dans le temps
mais il faut avoir une volonté un peu
continue voilà c'est ça le girly le
souci dans tout ça c'est que c'est qui
c'est qui gère ça c'est la sncf et du
coup la sncf
il faut savoir aussi quand même c'est le
premier transporteur routier de france
oui avec leurs filiales et ça c'est ça
tue tout dont le fret est du coup ça
fait que le fret ne reste pas dans celle
qui tue le fret lors le rail quoi
si vous parlez au sein si vous perdez
reçoit guillaume pepy oui c'est vrai ça
tombe bien
si vous parlez aujourd'hui fret
ferroviaire et dans son paradis c'était
bon mais du coup il ya des trains
corridor qui traverse tous les pays et
ronald mulder donc c'est le nom du train
c'est d'être inquiets d'un pays à un
autre
wheller sont par exemple la france ça va
jusqu'en norvège en suède ça va de
l'irlande jusqu'à jusqu'à ici avec des
changements via le dial maritime et en
france on n'a que deux gros axe corridor
1 pour l'italie 1 pour l'espagne
portugal
mais il ya des régions qui sont
délaissées comme en bretagne par exemple
mais vous avez une carte
oui j'ai une carte regarder ça guillaume
n'est pas venue seule mais y étaient
coupées voilà alors c'est quoi cette
carte donc cesser les trafics corridor
en europe le renvoi chorédanse ici il ya
un grand vide quand même la région
bretagne qui est une des régions les
plus importantes au niveau à groupe
agroalimentaire ya rien dessus il ya
quand même des questions à se poser
non mais c'est vrai il ya des trains
corridor partout sauf en france
il faut garder le truc pour demain
discrètement tout à coup j'ai lu est ce
que c'est et posez lui la question
s'arrêtera s'amusant tel qu'ils ne
regardent j'espère qu'ils n'ont l'air de
paris
posez lui la question pourquoi
maintenant le transport intérieur de
marchandises c'est 88% par la route à
peine neuf courses à peine 10% pardon
par le rail et le fluvial on n'en parle
même pas 2 %
les allemands au niveau trafic
ferroviaire toujours en interne ils en
sont à dix vit pourtant le fret
ferroviaire ans donc ça c'est les
chiffres qui datent de 2016 et la baisse
en france par rapport à 2015 ces 4 9%
hier et tout ça pourquoi parce que la
sncf
l'euphrate ur le faire ferroviaire par
leurs propres filiales qui sont des
filiales poids lourds pour une
entreprise ferroviaire faire du camion
c'est une aberration
moi je comprends page si guillaume pepy
peut s'expliquer là dessus stop
bravo encore il ya des dépenses de la
sncf sont pas pareils aberrante on
comprend pas ils sont ils ont créé oui
bus la première année ils sont ils ont
fini en déficit de 750 millions d'euros
la première année que pour huit bus la
deuxième année 250 millions ça fait 1
milliards et ils ont investi aussi 200
millions d'euros dans le projet de train
interlope là le train sous vide là donc
ça fait 1 milliard 200 millions d'euros
et ce montant là aurait pu être
mis dans la rénovation des voies ferrées
ce qui fait l'équivalent de 1200 km de
voies ferrées 9 rénové et oui mais
attendez c'est là la sncf les bois de
séparation c'est vrai que je suis
d'accord c'est un peu fort mais juste
pour finir ici très vite sur le sur le
transport combiné c'est évident qu'on
peut faire plus que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui moi j'ai pas dit qu'il
fallait pas en faire plus mais je j'ai
expliqué juste en fait d'où venaient les
avantages historiques du fret
ferroviaire et donc pourquoi ça
demandait des de penser quelque chose
d'un peu large et d'impôts long terme si
on veut rebasculer plus de trafic sur le
fret ferroviaire c'est juste ça peut
dire merci guillaume jeu même votre
petit papier genre et foch comme ça je
ne l'oublierai pas demain matin puisque
nous parle autres autre proposition qui
revient aussi assez souvent et qui est
dans les 30 pour l'instant redonner à
l'état la gestion des autoroutes alors
ça aura beaucoup parlé ça coûterait 20
milliards d'euros
ça dépend quand on le fait ouais d'un
milliard d'euros à l'état ça coûterait
en tout cas la privatisation a rapporté
moins que ça arrange première c'est
qu'on sait c'est vrai mais en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a donné à
des entreprises privées la concession
oui la concession court jusqu'à une
certaine date sait pas exactement quand
donc à l'expiration de la date s'il ne
se passe rien les autoroutes reviennent
à l'état et les gens la fin de la
concession
et si on veut les reprendre au
concessionnaire avant il ya un dédit
alors je ne sais pas quel est le montant
du dédit ça dépend de la réunion du coup
c'est impossible
alors si c'est possible ça coûterait
très cher et c'est pas aujourd'hui dans
les tuyaux donc mais le lycée qui a eu
une erreur certainement stratégique
parce que finalement le sahara porter
assez peu regard du rendement
aujourd'hui des autoroutes qui a eu
beaucoup d'investissements qui avait été
réalisé par le passé ça a été vendu au
moment où ces investissements ayant été
rentabilisé c'est plutôt ça permettrait
de modérer les prix bas prix l'état
récupère déjà une bonne partie des gens
tandis que les péages augmente en fait
c'est une fois sur deux c'est l'état qui
a décidé d augmenter
il ya eu par tj que alors parmi les
autres morizur jouer un peu un peu plus
vite parce que il y en a encore beaucoup
la suppression de la m e l'aide médicale
d'état
alors là oui non c'est je rappelle que
c'est une aide médicale qui permet aux
étrangers en situation irrégulière
d'accéder aux soins
elle est attribuée il faut quand même le
préciser parce qu'on ne précise jamais
sous condition de résidence stable et de
ressources le lien dossier a évidemment
monter qui est accordée pour un an
seulement 1
il faut résider en france depuis plus de
trois mois je le jeu je le précise parce
que oui si le sentiment d'un certain que
personne ne dira les étrangers pourrait
vite se soutiennent orienté de manière
gratuite chez nous pour ça car derrière
c'est aussi un discours tu peux être
anti anti immigration faut juste
rappeler que si on ne le fait pas on a
encore plus de risque de santé publique
tout cas sans de plus personne qui
arrive en france avec un nom de maladie
si en plus on les prend pas en compte
elles vont avant de démultiplier donc on
voit bien qu'on a aussi mesure
quel est votre votre prénom olivier et
on se comprend le problème du mauvais
côté allez-y c'est il faut pas supprimer
la m e mais il faut expulser les 325
mille personnes qui sont en situation
irrégulière qui ont pas droit de résider
sur le territoire français c'est à dire
qu'on ne supprime pas rennes mais rooney
ont reconduits dans leur pays ne sont
pas situation régulière il a une
définition sur des sommes pas demandeurs
d'asile et on connaît leur adresse parce
que qu'ils ont une carte vitale comme
les français il ya même deux cents de
ces quêtes socialement à paris qui gère
spécifiquement cette population on peut
sait parfaitement où ils sont et pour
mieux accueillir les migrants légaux
il faut qu'ils influent de retour vers
les pays pour ceux qui n'ont pas de
papiers en france qui veut réagir
non non il est intéressant c'est qu'on
voit bien derrière même c'est pas apparu
de manière très fort dans nos éléments
bien que la question des flux
migratoires est une vraie pro matic on
l'a sur les enseignants parce qu'à
certaines des nouveaux élèves qu'ils ont
ils viennent de l'institut tire bien sûr
c'est normalement comment on organise
je conte plein jeu complète avec une
autre proposition qui est dans les 30
pour l'instant qui est les quotas les
quotas d'immigration économique instauré
des quotas d'immigration économique
prenez un premier micro prenez un micro
et la france délivre 30000 permis
travail pour 20 millions de travailleurs
du privé c'est dérisoire
la pologne qui connut contre qui et
anti-immigration des livres 300 milles
permis travail à des étrangers
donc c'est pas ça le problème le
problème c'est c'est de reconduire aussi
des soixante mille réfugiés qui
demandent l'asile politique ils sont
déboutés pour pouvoir
agde accepter les étrangers en france il
faut que le fruit soit d'allers et de
retours mais pour expulser un étranger
il suffit pas que la france décide de
l'ex de reprendre il faut que son pays
d'origine
acceptes l'année dernier on a expulsé 17
malien parce que la molina refusent de
reprendre ses saillies goya et aux
comores par exemple le président refuse
depuis un an de reprendre les gens qui
sont à mayotte la france lui a dit on
vous coupe l'aide économique il est du
jeu n'a rien à faire c'est la chine qui
me paye mon nom mon aéropro est ce que
la france est prêt à perdre des
positions de l'afrique pour lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine
ça c'est le débat bien voulu ajouter une
chose non bon alors si comme les 1 90m
1726 au 98000 europe tiaré mille façons
allez passons à la fiscalité rmc.fr pour
voter passons la fiscalité l'économie
suppression des droits de succession
sauf pour les plus hauts revenus
notre place alors ça c'est assez été
plus hauts patrimoines
ce qu'il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui en
ligne directe en réalité plus de 80% des
successions donations sont pas taxés et
que en rallyes terre vous regardez les
abattements ses cent mille euros en
ligne directe par par an et par enfant
et donc sur ce qui est transmis aux îles
à peu près 80 % qui sont pas taxés cinq
ans vous êtes en ligne en direct
sexistes pas directement de parents
enfants par contre c'est taxer très
forte oui mais il est normal de taxer
moi je trouve qu'il serait peut-être
normal de taxer les très hauts
patrimoines les les héritages sur les
très hauts patrimoines ont alors on
taxer plus alors là c'est une autre
question donc séparé suppression les
taux marginaux augmentant avec les
montants qui sont transmis sachant
qu'ils vous pouvez transmettre cent
mille euros par par an et par enfant
tous les 15 ans donc si vous organisez
les traits les héritages pardo creuse
les inégalités
oui et non mais alors ça c'est un vrai
de vrai problème il ya une concurrence
fiscale aussi cassé féroce sur cette
question là nos voisins certains ont pas
du tout fiscalité sur les successions et
donations donc certains ont s'établir là
bas pour différentes raisons et
notamment des questions fiscales
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a ce
risque à rien on le voit dans certains
travaux c'est que on a une des rentes
qui s'accumulent 1 c'est pas forcément
ils vont aller de génération en
génération et qui sont pas forcément
favorables économistes d'abord il ya la
question des inégalités qui est derrière
mais il ya aussi le fait que passer
rentrent en fait crée pas de richesse un
réellement et donc la question des
inégalités elle est sous jacente à cette
fiscalité c'est comme avoir une
fiscalité juste
aujourd'hui on a des capitales qui se
transmettent de génération en génération
pour des montants qui sont importants et
en même temps il ya une valeur
symbolique extrêmement fort taux
succession c'est que ça c'est un impôt
qui est très impopulaire et donc
eric économiquement on aurait plutôt
tendance à dire s'ils voulaient pas
créer des sociétés de rentiers ils
voudraient me moins taxer le patrimoine
du vivant mais plus à la succession
aujourd'hui et un attachement très fort
est ce que chacun a envie de laisser
mais c'est les petites personnes mais il
faut l'avouer mais exonéré mais dans les
trois pour cent le taux de rendement
moyen est dans leur fait il dit on va me
prendre et du coup et c'est pas les plus
riches oui mais savent très bien sûr
mais lisez je ne paye pas et c'est vrai
que du coup l'argent va à l'argent quoi
wii de nintendo ça favorise pas à 10 ans
mes clients aussi le problème de la
transmission de l'entreprise d'étagés je
vais et par exemple par exemple un
vignoble situé dans une région qui tout
à coup a pris une valeur considérable
comment comment comment gérer la
succession très difficile et pas du coup
ça peut partir de france et du touquet
ce que j'ai obligé de vendre
et oui la famille est obligée de vendre
de l'or et pardon et là on est perdant
bien allocations familiales dès le
premier enfant est limitée à trois
enfants serge guérin alors on est un peu
dans tout à l'heure un buzz web avant
les familles qui font plus trois enfants
ouais c'est pas tout le monde voilà
plutôt des gens issus du sud de
l'immigration à 7,8 donc derrière je
pense qu'un petit peu cette idée là de
manière assez assez forte de se dire il
ya des gens vous croyez en ce sens je
suis pas certain que globalement le à
l'événement c'est celui-là les gens qui
font plein d'enfants oui oui mais c'est
certain que nous on estime dans la
proposition oui mais sinon c'est l'autre
élément c'est de se dire la réalité
c'est faire des enfants
5 et donc c'est aussi si on commence
plus tôt dès le premier d'une certaine
manière on soutient sans doute mais
c'est normal la natalité lalo moi je
pense que ce serait normal allocations
familiales dès le premier enfant
on a un pour mettre les pieds dans le
plat
on a quand même un tout petit sujet sur
cette planète qui s'appelle la taille de
la population
on a compris en narrateur un tout petit
sujet il m'a fait c'est pas les 66
millions de français qui jouent c'est
parce que je suis en train de dire je
cachais enfin dire c'est que ça
s'inscrit dans un dans une réflexion un
peu plus large
par ailleurs on a aussi dans un monde
aux ressources limitées un arbitrage à
faire entre les jeunes et les vieux
et aussi un vrai sujet tout à l'heure on
parlait de la santé tout ce qu'on donne
aujourd'hui dans les années le mauvaises
conditions de vie c'est autant que qui
est pas disponible pour des gens quand
ils sont beaucoup plus jeunes à mon avis
les c'est un débat difficile mais on va
pas régler en 2d là pourquoi je crois
bien que nous pourrons poser génération
comme ça mais non nos ressources il ya
les mêmes ressources il ya une vraie
tradition de politique familiale en
france ou si c'est pour les 7 à partir
du deuxième enfant mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya la question des familles
monoparentales un casier sur rassurant
tout ça fasse moins songeur des dragons
il ya près d'un an et demi à 8
jacques c'est un tout petit peu en est à
combien de votre là j'aimerais savoir 97
1908 on va passer de 90 ml de sang déçu
le paiement de l'impôt sur revenu de
m'arrêter si vous voulez dire quelque
chose vraiment de paiement de il faut
qu'on fasse cours sur chaque
intervention paiement de l'impôt sur le
revenu dès le premier organisme c'est
important surtout que dans le jdd la
parler ça fait beaucoup les médias
aujourd'hui
non la question moi je tombe sur aucun
sens je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
que tout le monde paie hier d'impôts
alors la csg s'appelle pas en position
connue mais c'est l'impôt sur le revenu
qui a pas collectivement les mêmes
propriétés et événementiel gcg pour le
coup c'est surtout les rognons choses-là
et chômeurs retraités revenus d'activité
revenus du pétrole vous payez une cg sûr
que les taux sont fixes et part
proportionnelle dans ta question qui se
poserait c est ce qu on doit pas faire à
un gros d'impôt sur le revenu qui
rassemble les deux de façon à constituer
quelque chose qui soit plus lisible plus
transparent je dis juste pour exemple
pour les retraités aujourd'hui on a
quatre taux de csg donc quelque part on
commence à plus rien comprendre ou aller
faire quelque chose symbolique n'a pas
d'intérêt surtout je vous rappeler
quelque chose c'est que le cou
coût de 2,2 de récupérer la collecte la
boue survenues ce à peu près 60 euros
par foyer fiscal donc plus cher ça
coûterait plus cher ça aucun sens alors
y'a aussi fin de tous les régimes
spéciaux de retraite
c'est l'heure les 30 est dans les tuyaux
ça passait dans les duels que là il ya
une réforme du régime de retraite qui
passerait peut-être sur une sorte de
régime à points est donc appartement on
considère en tout cas c'est ce que le
président de république a mis en avant
que anne euro cotisé de couvre les mêmes
droits la question des régimes spéciaux
à se poser il ya bien deux régimes
aujourd'hui les gens sont convaincus que
du coup il ya les inégalités donc
l'intérêt trek au moins tout le monde a
l'impression qu'il est à égalité après
ça se discutera beaucoup enfin si tu
survis démocratique donc réduction du
nombre de parlementaires 577 députés 348
sénateurs ça ne vous surprendra pas
c'est dans les 30 pour l'instant mais
d'abord c'est j'allais dire dans le
tuyau oui étatique puisque c'est quelque
chose qui a été déposé devant
l'assemblée nationale l'année dernière
et que si la révision constitutionnelle
et institutionnelle reprend il est
probable que cette réforme sera adoptée
je pense qu'il ya sans doute une idée un
peu sanctionna trice à l'égard des
parlementaires là encore l'idée qu' ils
sont trop nombreux
enfin ça rejoint ce qu'on a entendu tout
à l'heure sur les niveaux de
rémunération etc
ça pose quand même une question qui est
que
les parlementaires sont là pour nous
représenter et que bas malgré tout si on
diminue leur nombre ça veut dire que
chacun aura vocation à représenter
encore plus de gens et compte
aujourd'hui on n'entend qu'une des
critiques à l'égard des politiques c'est
on n'est pas entendu je passe sur
continuant le nombre de représentants ça
favorise l'écouté d'éventuelles
revendications et après j'entends le
message là encore c'est pas ça qui
l'attend les productions de leur temps
personnel pour législatives là aussi
c'est dans les tuyaux
un troll est dans les tuyaux c'est un
vieux débat ça a été on l'a vécu soit
mitterrand alors on l'a vécu une fois
est dans une configuration particulière
puisqu'on les a été de la
proportionnelle intégrale 100 watts en
assemblée nationale élue à la
proportionnelle
là ce qui est proposé aujourd'hui parce
que tout le monde trouve que le scrutin
majoritaire a des avantages notamment le
fait de pouvoir dégager une majorité qui
permet au gouvernement de mener sa
politique
ce qu'on propose c'est une dose de
proportionnelle vrais mecs qui veulent
la proportionnelle sont ceux qui sont
pas assez représentées et donc la dose
sera jamais tout à fait assez importante
pour que ils le soient correctement
alors une minute je vais vous demander
de réfléchir à 4 minutes à une
proposition que vous feriez vous une
proposition un qui vous semblerait très
intéressante réfléchissez vite on va le
référendum suppression de l'sf ça vous
surprend qu'elle ne soit pas que ces
mesures-là ne soit pas dans les 30
formations de loi citoyenne savoir on a
tellement parlé il pouvait s'attendre à
ce que je sois vraiment et ça prouve rpa
passé et s est auto début propositions
puis après ça c'était ce qu'on remarque
quand même c'est que l'essentiel de il y
en a trop il en faut moins concerne le
public et privé oui il n'y a pas
d'enfant tout cas dans ce que vous avez
donné il ya eu de revendications qui
concernent les grosses fortunes les gens
qu'il ya quand même dans les 60 il ya et
25000 contribution des parts dans les
soixante et une cheville je veillerai au
patrimoine je vais jouer comme exemple
inscrire dans la constitution un taux
maximal de prélèvement pour tous les
contribuables
une sorte de bouclier fiscal des
demandes et dans les 60 propositions
arrêt du versement des allocations
chômage si un demandeur d'emploi refusé
une offre quelle qu'elle soit
existe en grande bretagne au danemark
par exemple
oui il ya aussi des propositions qui
sont à provisions très libérale repérer
les gens oui j'en suis là il fait pas
assez d'efforts on voit bien je voulais
dire c'est que la la la critique a été
très dirigé sur les gens du public dans
les choses qui arrivent qui arrivait à
nouveau en grève dans les entreprises
instituts et non mais je trouve ça
étonnant parce que encore une fois on
aurait pu s'attendre à ce que il ya une
culture de l'état quoi oui décidées par
l'epa par les entreprises moi j'ai une
question d'envoyer ya rien sur la taxe
carbone sur la taxe carbone rien alors
j'aime le début du tout non mais ya rien
alors attendez je vous dis non je vous
dire d'écriture du prix des loyers
indexation du prix des loyers sur la
qualité de l'isolation la vétusté du
logement l'instauration d'une taxe au
kilomètre sur tous les produits pour
favoriser les circuits courts rendre la
taxe d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
proportionnelle au poids des poubelles
ses revenus assez souvent ça aussi et ça
fait débardeur ça fait vraiment débat
qu'est-ce que j'ai encore créer un droit
aux déplacements propres obliger les
collectivités à proposer une alternative
à la voiture individuelle qu'on
voiturage autopartage aux lignes de
train
il ya des choses à creuser dans tout ça
qu'il ne faut pas position si vous aviez
une proposition à faire un geste et sur
mon terrain institutionnel
[Musique]
alors j'entends bien que le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne finalement et
peut-être pas aussi prioritaire que ça
malgré tout je pense que ya quand même
une demande et
bien sûr le montre de propositions de la
part des citoyens et je pense que il ya
il ya un droit qui existent d'ores et
déjà mais qui est complètement oubliée
et pas utilisé par les citoyens il
faudrait pas grand chose pour le
réactiver
c'est le droit de pétition et je trouve
que si finalement les citoyens s'emparer
de ce droit c'est à dire saisissez les
parlementaires et que les parlementaires
les traite différemment aujourd'hui il
ya une trentaine de pétitions déposées
devant chacune des assemblées chaque
année autant dire rien du tout si en
revanche il y avait un dispositif qui
permette en fait aux électeurs aux
citoyens et aux parlementaires de
réfléchir ensemble sur certains c'est à
dire que son atteindrait chaque mois 500
mille signataires ou un million de
signataires les parlementaires c'est
obligé de proposer la loi
en tout cas qui est une formule de
propositions citoyennes c'est à dire que
les citoyens puissent demander alors
parlementaires de se saisir d'un certain
sujet on pourrait fixer un nombre de
signatures pas très élevées pour que ça
vienne dans la discussion et ya un
travail de corée d'action ensemble jean
marc jancovici propositions alors
puisqu'on sait de l'époque du salon de
l'agriculture
personnellement je pense alors c'est un
tout petit sujet avec l'europe mais je
pense qu'il faudrait encadrer les prix
agricoles ray encadré bon je pense qu'il
faut réfléchir à un impôt plus lisible
et par exemple c'est qu'ils sont d'impôt
survenu de la crg doit se poser si on
veut redonner la progressivité système
fiscal
sachant que maintenant elles prennent
nettement la source et qu'on a augmenté
les tranches les niches et et a donc on
n'y comprend plus rien donc je pense
qu'il faudrait repenser ces deux impôts
ensemble ça c'est un problème il va
avoir parlé de cette taxe carbone pour
moi je pense qu'il faut une compensation
intégrale en faisant quelque chose de
forfaitaire qui donnait la
redistribution mais en même temps la
taxe carbone est importante parce qu'il
va faire un signal prix fort à faire
qu'au bout d'un moment l'énergie doit
être plus taxés mais il faut
redistribuer pour éviter les effets sur
le partage a donc distribuer un chèque
équivalent à tout le monde et en fait on
voit que c'est plutôt redistributif
et puis moi j'ai une question autour des
emplois aidés
du coup les employés les emplois
d'avenir pour les jeunes car quand le
système privé les prend pas en termes
d'emplois ces jeunes-là qui soit assez
loin du système quattro faire quelque
chose dont je pense qu'il ya quand même
socialement une utilité sur ce type
d'emploi coque et serge guérin tiens
vous interromps on parle du principe de
précaution je dirais un principe de
prévention inventé une société de la
prévention par prévention c'est la santé
évidemment ces activités physiques c'est
la nutrition la prévention c'est le
logement l'adaptation des logements mais
la prévention
moi j'ai rien master jai des étudiants
qui ont de 23 cents à 58 la prévention
c'est aussi le droit de pouvoir
continuer à se former pour justement
retrouver un emploi ainsi de suite
faire de la prévention le fer de lance
la pensée générale pour pour inventer
une société eh bien merci
ce sera la conclusion 3,98 1380 les cent
mille merci merci vraiment à vous tous
je remercie toutes celles et ceux qui
sont venus passer la soirée avec nous en
direct ici sur rmc story cette émission
rien est impossible et d'ailleurs notre
prochaine émission sera consacrée encore
aux propositions le 25 mars et les
propositions nous les auront en main les
30 propositions définitivement ils nous
auront donné à tous les politiques nous
verrons justement le 25 mars ce qu'ils
en font de ces propositions bien merci
à nova d' merci jean marc jancovici
mathieu plane et serge guérin merci et
bonne soirée avec lui
[Musique]